poutine est en train de s'exprimer on va
l'écouter nous avons signé des amis ron
accords qui ont été signés avec les
rythmes populaires de donetsk est
lougansk comprenait notamment
une disposition qui disait qu'il fallait
qu'on apporte une aide d'un million
terre entre autres à ces républiques
après 2015 en cas de crise on comprendre
qu'en cas de nécessité le cas échéant
nous serons à la hauteur de nos
engagements
bonjour agence
toute évidence et l'ukraine ne veut pas
reconnaître la souveraineté des
républiques populaires à donetsk de
lougansk ils sont pas contents
de leur ce
jeudi à kiev l'ukraine ne reconnaît pas
les riches et les populaires de donetsk
de lougansk en tant qu'entité s'ouvrait
moi j'ai que le crès j'ai pas content de
voir notre vie décision de perspectives
la suite à cela un ace que j'ai envoyé
des perspectives pour améliorer les
relations entre moscou et qui ava parce
que moscou et devrait faire et qu'il
devrait faire pour y arriver vous savez
ce sont des questions dont nous avons
parlé pendant des heures lors des
rencontres avec nos partenaires
européens
et puis avec les américains également
nous en avons parlé à de nombreuses
reprises je ne l'avais pas dit
publiquement je vous crois mais je vous
le dirai et si la question est posée que
devraient être faits et des deux côtés
ou du côté deux tiers pour que nous
puissions penser que la situation est
réglée à long terme pour la perspective
historique et pour que nous puissions
vivre tranquillement en paix
qu'il s'agisse pas de conflit est
d'autant plus de conflit militaire eh
bien je dévoilerai le secret mais il n'y
a rien de secret après à tous qu'il faut
reconnaître c'est qu'elle fait
reconnaître la volonté
exprimée par les gens qui vivent à
sébastopol et en crimée pourquoi quand
ils ont exprimé leur volonté c'était
moins bien que ce qui s'était passé au
kosovo il y avait rien de moins bien
mais là bas la décision a été prise par
le parlement ici la décision a été prise
le référendum populaire je voudrais
souligner une fois de plus que personne
ne pouvait forcer les gens à venir
exprimer leur volonté dans les bureaux
de vote en étant un pistolet à leur
temps pas du tout ils sont venus de leur
propre gré et ils ont exprimé leur
volonté et ceux qui débattent ou le
conteste
doivent reconnaître qu'il s'agit du plus
haut niveau de démocratie que j'étais un
référendum populaire
deuxièmement nous voyons que il y à des
discussions à washington
l'otan et la russie nous sommes contre
l'adhésion de l'ukraine à l'otan car
ceux ci représentent une menace pour
nous et j'ai présenté à de nombreuses
reprises les arguments pour une fois je
les fais dans cette salle eh bien je
nous devons en comprendre et nous
entendons notamment dans les capitales
occidentales ont parlé que la meilleure
solution de cette question serait pour
que nos collègues à l'occident ne perde
pas la face comment comme on dit c'est
que les autorités ukrainiennes
aujourd'hui refusent d'elle-même
renoncent à leur adhésion du futur a le
temps qui est les autres tels qu ils
mettent en place l'idée de cette étude
une autre de leur pays et troisièmement
et malheureusement ce jeu m'a
pratiquement perdu son actualité mais
j'avais dit que pour résoudre le
problème tu donnes passe par la voie de
pourparlers de paix et par la mise en
place des accords 2015 et puis le plus
important le quatrième main c'est que
tout ce que j'avais dit au dessus peut
être changée à d'un instant à l'autre
si nos partenaires un
pompe désarmement en ukraine apporte une
grande quantité d'armement en ukraine
pour les autorités ukrainiennes actuelle
il est important de démilitariser le
cren contemporaine
car c'est le seul facteur qui fait
contrôler de manière objective que l'on
peut observer et auquel on peut réagir
tout le reste peut être renversée et
changer entièrement du jour au lendemain
comme ce qui a été fait par l'ue leder
ukrainien actuelle qui a un v
du coup commencé à poursuivre l'ancien
un leader qui craignent à riom bien en
disant qu'il n'aime pas les accords de
minsk avait désavoué tous les accords
possibles dont je viens de parler cissé
accord était signé par les autorités
ukrainiennes
actuelle il partirait tout simplement
vivre à washington paris berlin et nous
nous nous serions ici avec une entier
russie armés jusqu'aux dents à notre
porte
ceci serait inacceptable et c'est
inacceptable surtout maintenant que les
autorités ukrainiennes ont parlé de
leurs ambitions nucléaires
le président vous êtes adressé aux
citoyens russes et vous avez mentionné
les paroles d erin ce qu'ils disaient
que le prix pourrait à nouveau avoir une
larme au nucléaire elle l'ukraine
pourrait de nouveau se joindront aux
filles qui possède l'armé claire est ce
que c'est juste des paroles un
d'événements parole je vais où c'est une
probabilité tout à fait
actuel je viens d'en parler j'ai compris
que ses paroles nous étaient adressées
avant tout à nous et elles ne sont pas
tombées dans l'oreille d'un sourd
l'ukraine a deux filles 1 l'union
soviétique
possède de nombreuses compétences
nucléaires il ya plusieurs unités un
nucléaire et l'industrie nucléaire du
nucléaire est bien développée il ya
aussi des écoles qui fonderait des
spécialistes il y a tout ce qu'il faut
pour
obtenir
la solution au nucléaire au plus
rapidement que de nombreuses autres
piles qui devrait le faire à partir
d'une page blanche à partir de zéro ce
n'est pas le cas de l'ukraine donc je ne
pas répéter une phase plus la seule
chose qui leur faut c'est
l'enrichissement d'uranium a mais ce
système d'enrichissement c'est une
question purement des cuisses car même
ceux ne représente pas un problème
insoluble pour l'ukraine c'est assez
facile à résoudre et en ce qui concerne
les vecteurs et bien un jean n'est pas
rien il y a je les aimais ancien missile
tout cas où et leurs portes et ses 110
kg mais prière j'avais 10 ans km une a
fait ses 110 km et ce n'est pas un
problème a car il y à bien une usine
views match qu'ils préparaient qui est
fabriqué des missiles intercontinentaux
balistique pour l'union soviétique mais
alors quel est le problème c'est que
même si ces armes nucléaires tactiques
qui apparaît en ukraine elle représente
à une menace stratégique pour nous et
nous devons
avoir à l'esprit car si nous commençons
par 110 km nous pouvons ensuite allé
très vite jusqu'à 300 350 km et sera
donc moscou serait à apporter et serait
calme mis à la portée de ses missiles
facile à atteindre et c'est bien ce que
nous avons compris perçu et nous devons
et nous allons le prendre très au
sérieux les
récollets kolesnikov
je l'admirais vladimirovitch est-ce que
vous pensez que dans le monde
contemporain on veut
avoir des solution par la force est
restée un dieu côté
de la force positive
parce qu'elle pour un hoax imiter
pourrait
avancer ses troupes quelle pourrait être
la distance de pénétration des troupes
jusqu'à la frontière de des républicains
populaire ou plus loin tout d'abord je
n'ai pas dit que les troupes irait là
tout de suite là bas après notre
rencontre
deuxièmement
je ne peux prédire le schéma de ce qui
se passera est impossible ceci dépendra
de la situation réelle sur le terrain et
puis en ce qui concerne la question
est-ce qu'il faut tout résoudre est-ce
qu'on peut tout résoudre par la force et
est resté du côté des forces du bien
pourquoi vous pensez que les forces du
bien doivent être impuissante je ne le
crois pas je pense que les forces du
bien justement doivent avoir les forces
de se défendre mais essaie de ces
postulats que nous partons et je vous
remercie 1